it all started in 2008 when Nick Fury
told Tony Stark about the Avengers
initiative and ten years after iron man
hit theaters
Earth's Mightiest Heroes are set to face
their toughest challenge Thanos the mad
Titan directed by Joe and Anthony Russo
Avengers infinity war will feature at
least 76 characters be Marvel's longest
movie to date and revolve around six
mysterious stones well seven if you
count Deadpool's continuity Jim which
they won't it's a lot to keep track of
so if you need a primer to prepare for
history's biggest superhero movie here's
everything you need to know before
seeing Avengers infinity war who is
stano's the mad Titan first appeared in
the mid credit scene for the Avengers
since then he's popped up a few other
times but we haven't really gotten to
know the guy what does he want with
Earth's Mightiest Heroes his purple is a
magic glove doesn't like standing up in
the comics Thanos is a member of the
Eternals a race of genetically
engineered superhumans who colonized
Titan Saturn's largest moon incredibly
intelligent uber powerful and born
deformed thanks to a mutant gene fan OHS
is absolutely obsessed with death the
actual personification of death hoping
to win her love Thanos destroys half the
universe with the help of the infinity
gems we don't know how much of that
backstory will play into the film but
it's clear that us means business and
when he comes to complete his rock
collection the mad Titan might teach the
Avengers what it's like to lose alien
sidekicks
when Fanus arrives he'll have plenty of
backup the big baddie has a massive
extraterrestrial army but he's also
bringing his very own evil supergroup
the black order in the comics these are
Thanos his top generals and while there
are usually five it looks like we're
only getting four in the movie the
Infinity stones we know Fanus wants to
get his big purple hands on the Infinity
stones but what are they exactly we know
a bit about their history thanks to the
collector then
exploded into existence and the remnants
of these systems were forged into
concentrated ingots as a result these
six stones come equipped with
devastating powers let's break them down
officially debuting in Captain America
the First Avenger the space stone is a
blue gem inside a glowing cube and it
can open portals across the universe and
if the space stone lives up to its
comic-book potential then Thanos might
gain the ability of omnipresence or
being everywhere at once
then there's the mind stone which
powered Loki's staff and the Avengers
although it looks blue there the mind
stone is actually yellow and can
hypnotize and manipulate its victims the
Power Stone is the purple orb that
appeared in guardians of the galaxy it
enhances its user's strength and can
waste entire planets in the comics it
also supercharges the rest of the stones
making them all more powerful green and
stored inside a magical locket the time
stone showed up in Doctor Strange and
grants its user the ability to reverse
time and create time loops to bargain
actually I can the most perplexing Jim
is the reality stone it debuted in Thor
the dark world is a sentient red goo and
while we haven't seen its full powers
yet in the comics it can be used to
alter the nature of reality itself
there's one final rock that we haven't
seen yet in orange Jim known as the soul
stone in the comics this allowed Thanos
to control all living Souls and even
resurrect deceased ones where are they
according to the infinity war trailers
Thanos will definitely get the space
stone and the Power Stone so where the
rest of the stones Doctor Strange placed
the time stone inside the magical
compound of kamar Taj and following the
events of Thor the dark world the
reality stone was given to the collector
though after the explosive events of
guardians of the galaxy who knows if he
still has it and then there's the mind
stone which has been everywhere in age
of Ultron the mind stone ended up in
visions forehead granting him the
ability to fly shoot lasers and walk
through walls as for the soul stone
nobody knows where it's hiding there are
plenty of theories being kicked around
maybe Heimdall has it maybe it won't
show up until Avengers 4 or maybe fan
OHS has had it all along
torn Avengers by the end of Captain
America's Civil War the Avengers were
still split Captain America has given up
the shield and his star-spangled
identity and gone on the run Tony Stark
on the other hand is still working with
vision and war machine and the Russo
brothers promise infinity war will
grapple with the results of the last
Captain America movie if the Avengers
hope to defeat the Earth's
extraterrestrial threat they'll have to
put personal differences aside Guardian
grudges star-lord and his band of
misfits will finally meet the Avengers
in infinity war and really this battle
against Thanos is far more personal for
the Guardians than it is for the rest of
the heroes nebula and Gomorrah were
adopted by Thanos his kids and turned
into super assassins nebula has grown up
hating fan house and getting revenge
against her stepdad as nebulas number
one priority I will hunt my father like
a dog and I will tear him apart slowly
piece by piece Drax the destroyer is
also on the hunt for Thanos because he
had Drax's family slain and with her own
dark past involving fan OHS Gamora isn't
a big fan of her adoptive father either
when Thanos took my homeworld he killed
my parents in front of me he tortured me
turned me into a weapon seen Scarlett
chances are pretty good the vision won't
make it out of infinity war alive
considering panels wants the mine stone
and it's lodged squarely in visions
forehead
The Scarlet Witch also got her psychic
powers from that particular gym so maybe
that's why she and vision get along so
well
there was definitely romantic tension
between the two in Captain America Civil
War and that might develop into a
full-blown romance for infinity war
elizabeth Olsen told Nerdist that her
infinity war performance is her most
emotional arc in an Avengers movie it's
a love affair that lines up with the
comics and it'll be interesting to see
how the to pull off this star-crossed
affair considering they run different
sides in civil war of course their
romance will make it way more painful if
the Black Order rips that rock out of
vision's head first meeting thor
ragnarok saw the Hulk and Thor on a
different path from the rest of the
Avengers and in a different part of the
universe and as the film came to an end
things took a very dark turn meek who
were you from well mixed eat oh yeah I
accidentally stomped on him on the
bridge nope not that in ragnaroks mid
credit sequence the Asgardians were
dwarfed by an ominous warship MCU
producer Kevin Feige confirmed that the
craft is the sanctuary to Thanos his
flagship chances are good that Thanos
will capture the Asgardian ship probably
to steal the space stone that Loki most
likely snatched from Odin's throne room
homefront well Kondo was once thought of
as a third world country until it turned
out to be super high-tech thanks to a
particular resource I don't follow
what comes out of Wakanda
the strongest metal on earth but why is
Wakanda going to play such a pivotal
part in the film well get ready for
minor spoilers according to Anthony
Russo the mine stone is going to end up
in two challahs homeland so it makes
sense that Thanos and his army will
battle the Avengers in black panther's
warriors on the wakandan plains black
panther has also been protecting Steve
Rogers his best friend Bucky Barnes
since Captain America's Civil War until
recently Bucky has been sleeping in a
hibernation chamber but in a
post-credits scene in black panther the
newly armed super soldier was out and
about again so when the wakandans
face-off against Thanos Bucky will be
right there with them missing Avengers
Avengers infinity war is definitely
going to be crowded and several of the
main heroes have already been lost in
the marketing shuffle spider-man and
Doctor Strange have both shown up in the
film's trailers but where exactly are
Hawk Eye and ant-man Clint Barton and
Scott Lang are pretty big players in the
MCU but neither have appeared in the
trailers or on the official poster so
have these two Avengers gone AWOL or
will they help take on the mad Titan
according to the Russo brothers Hawkeye
is still around but he's living a
different life than his superhero
buddies as they explained Hawk eyes on
his own journey in this movie he has a
unique reaction to the Civil War
situation that puts him in a special
spot in this film as for ant-man slash
film reports that he'll show up in the
film and Paul Rudd is listed on the cast
list
so maybe the tiniest Avenger is lurking
in the trailer somewhere but we just
can't spot him he could even be inside
someone's suit who's speaking
mr. conscience we don't talk a lot these
days thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]